[Music]
should we watch some nick cage
yeah yeah i guess kyle did you send that
article about nick cage and all the
movies that he did over the last like
three years or did i just read that
randomly well you don't know how to read
so i don't know how you would have done
that
well i looked at the pictures
yeah i did i looked at all the pictures
i think that was a separate article okay
yeah he did an interview basically
talking about all the indie roles he did
over the last two three years because he
did a [ __ ] ton yeah he took all these
roles to get out of debt and now he's
out of debt i think he owed the irs like
75 million bucks or something like that
and he did it he paid them off and he
never declared bankruptcy wow and the
article was like actually pretty honest
he's just like yeah i had to do this and
he's like but everything i took i didn't
just take roles i had to make sure that
i actually liked it and it meant
something to me wow
pretty cool i mean that just kind of
like begs a question like everyone's
like oh he's a bad actor but it's like
is he
no two of those movies are like
critically acclaimed well which ones pig
and mandy i can't believe people liked
pig pig's really popular i know that's
one where
didn't quite get me with that one so i
don't know if this clip is is funny at
all but i think we should try it nick
cage replies to fans on the internet all
right let's go
social media i i i i
it's antithetical to my beliefs but here
i am doing this
yes hello gq i'm nicholas k hard as hell
antithetical to my beliefs yeah what
beliefs i don't believe in social media
i don't actually believe it exists no he
believes you should never dance for free
you should never get on tick tock live
and get clapped for free asian today i'm
going undercover on the internet on the
it's actually internet
whatever the [ __ ] that is hey me it's
it's nick cage my cage
i read it
dude i want to just
clip that and use it forever reddit
reddit
i did hear that reddit has a sub
something about me you know what it's
called yeah i've heard about it i'm not
gonna say it
that would be arrogant
what movie role would have been improved
by casting nicholas cage i can't answer
that either because that would be
arrogant next that was his answer come
on dude you're [ __ ] nicholas cage be
a little arrogant inception yeah he
should have replaced leo yeah any movie
actually
any movie i'm just trying to think yeah
he should have been um captain marvel
can you imagine he says that [ __ ] he's
like
i would have done way better as captain
marvel
they've completely [ __ ] it with brie
larson
i'm a way better woman than she is
nicholas cage spent 150 million on a 70
million year old dinosaur skull there's
the skull i bought at an auction i
bought it legally here's the macguffin
when the mongolian government said that
they needed it back i gave it to him but
i never got my money back so somebody at
the auction house should be in jail
whoa
still harbor some resentment oh yeah
that's a sticky situation
yeah e-i-l nicholas cage and gary allman
were the original i love how he says it
out loud t-i-l
choices to play harry and lloyd really
i didn't know that
i thought it was jim from the beginning
i know jim wanted me to be in it with
him but i wanted to do a little movie
called leaving las vegas instead all the
people in the comments like who the [ __ ]
is rando
just acting like he is nicholas cage
yeah why are all of his answers in this
perspective it's weird
i honestly think on this subreddit you
know if he's answering from the i
perspective to people will be like oh
yeah he's here that's it yeah nick he
browses yeah yeah we know he's a lurker
yeah he's our boy i read it
i read it
wikipedia
wikipedia wikipedia is something that
people go in and they change
any way they want so i'm not sure all
the facts are true in wikipedia but at
15 years old he tried to commit to his
uncle francis ford copa to give him a
screen test telling him i'll show you
hacking that's in fact yeah that did
happen and i was met by silence in the
car
cool all right we can stop watching this
well now i'm intrigued i do like him i
think we should try and get him on the
show there's no way but yeah we should
we have to he [ __ ] did this [ __ ] i
just wanted what is this let's just make
up of some dumbass series like this i
just wanted to uh come up here and just
sit i don't want him to say anything
yeah the most i wanted to do is just sit
there and go
reddit
read it